♪ ♪
>> Greg: MARIA DOCOMO NOT HER
REAL NAME, IS A COMEDIAN.
HERE'S HER PICTURE.
SHE WENT TO COURT TO CHANGE IT.
SHE FILED A RESTRAINING ORDER.
WAS IT EVER DANCED OF VIOLENCE
STALKER?
NO.
IT WAS AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
SHE CITED ANXIETY OVER COMMENTS
ON NUCLEAR WAR, SO SHE WENT TO
COURT, WAITED IN LINE, FILLED
OUT PAPERWORK, BUT SADLY SHE WAS
DENIED.
YOU CAN CALL THIS ART OR
SELF-PROMOTION.
I CALL IT CLUELESS.
SHE IS DOING THIS AS WE DROPPED
MISSILES ON SYRIA.
HER ACTIONS ACTUALLY IGNORE
TRUMP'S REAL RESPONSE TO ACTUAL
SUFFERING.
AS OPPOSED TO WHAT'S GOING ON IN
HER HEAD.
SHE'S NOT UP-TO-DATE ON WORLD
EVENTS.
THE RISK FOR NUCLEAR WAR IS
SHRINKING.
NORTH AND SOUTH KOREA ARE
PLANNING SERIOUS TALKS.
MORE IMPORTANT, CHANCES ARE WE
ALL KNOW WOMEN, MOMS, SISTERS,
COWORKERS FACED WITH THREATS WHO
HAVE HAD TO FILE RESTRAINING
ORDERS.
IT'S NOT COMEDY.
IT IS TERROR.
THAT MARIA WAS IN A GOVERNMENT
OFFICE WASTING VALUABLE TIME
PERHAPS MY OTHER WOMEN WERE
WAITING TO GET REAL RESTRAINING
ORDERS AGAINST REAL THREATS
MAKES THIS JOKE LESS FUNNY.
I DOUBT THE WOMEN HAVE THE TIME
FOR CLUB OR -- CLEVER P.R.
STUNTS.
BUT BECAUSE SHE HATES CHUM, SHE
WILL BE CHEERED.
NOT SO MUCH BY VICTIMS SEEKING
WHAT DO THEY KNOW ABOUT COMEDY?
DANA, SHE HAS BACKED OFF.
I DIDN'T MENTION HER NAME
BECAUSE I FELT IT WOULD FEED
INTO THE P.R. THING.
DON'T GIVE IT TO HER.
>> Dana: SHREWD IN YOUR IDEA
OF NOT GETTING THESE PEOPLE
ATTENTION.
>> Greg: IF YOU ARE GOING TO
DO A STAND, DON'T DO IT DID
OTHER PEOPLE'S EXPENSE.
YOU KNOW?
THINKING OF ALL THE SOUNDS I'VE
DONE.
>> Dana: SAYS SHE IS
WELL-KNOWN FOR JOKES ABOUT
DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY.
THAT'S NOT VERY FUNNY.
>> Greg: IT IS TO ME, BUT I
HAVE H.
>> Kimberly: YOURS IS AMAZING
ON A PLANE.
SO KNOTS.
>> Greg: LET'S NOT BRING UP
PLANES.
ANYWAY, I DON'T THINK SHE IS
UPON CURRENT EVENTS.
>> Jesse: I THINK YOU GOT
HOSED BY THIS PERSON.
SHE WANTED TO DO THIS STUNT AND
NOW SHE IS THE SUBJECT OF A
MONOLOGUE.
>> Greg: BUT THERE IS NO NAME.
>> Jesse: EVERYBODY SEES
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
SHE GOT A HUGE PROMOTIONAL BLOG,
AND YOU ARE SCHOOLMARMING HER.
>> Jesse: IT'S NOT LIKE SHE
CALLED 911.
>> Greg: WAITING IN LINE WHILE
SOMEONE ELSE IS BEHIND YOU TO DO
A STUNT?
KIMBERLY, YOU ARE A PROSECUTOR.
YOU DEAL WITH RESTRAINING
ORDERS.
DO YOU THINK IT'S FUNNY TO USE A
RESTRAINING ORDER IS A POLITICAL
STUNT?
>> Kimberly: NO, BECAUSE THERE
ARE PEOPLE WHO REALLY NEED THEM.
>> Greg: THAT'S MY POINT.
>> Kimberly: VERY SERIOUS
CASES OUT THERE WHEN THEY ARE
UTILIZED TO PROTECT PUBLIC
SAFETY AND IN INDIVIDUALS SAFETY
SAFETY AND IN INDIVIDUALS SAFET
SAFETY.
THAT BEING THE CASE, YOU STILL
DID THIS BECAUSE YOU BELIEVED IN
IT.
AND JESSE THREW SHADE AT YOU.
>> Jesse: I DID.
IF SOMEONE HAD FILED A
RESTRAINING ORDER AGAINST OBAMA,
I WOULD'VE HAD HIM ON MY SHOW.
>> Kimberly: AT LEAST YOU'RE
HONEST.
WATERS WORLD.
WACKY WORLD.
>> Greg: WHY ARE SO COMEDIAN'S
THROAT EMOTIONALLY TRAUMATIZED
BY TRUMP?
>> Juan: WHAT IS THE NAME OF
THE COMEDIAN WHO WAS HOLDING HIS
HEAD.
>> Greg: KATHY GRIFFIN.
>> Juan: SHE IS BACK NOW.
>> Greg: I KNOW.
>> Juan: MAY BE IT'S KIND OF
DESPERATE.
ON THE OTHER HAND, I AM NOT
GOING TO MAKE FUN OF SOMEONE
SUFFERING FROM DEPRESSION.
SHE SAYS IT MADE HER MORE
ANXIOUS BECAUSE OF TRUMP'S
LANGUAGE.
THE BIG BUTTON AND ALL OF THAT.
>> Dana: IT SHE WATCH THE
SOUTH PARK EPISODE ABOUT THIS.